after you become the 47th president what
are you gonna do to stop the war in
Ukraine yeah so I would literally start
calling not from the day I took over but
from the night I won and I called two
people two people you know the two
people are Putin right you know Putin is
and zielinsky zielinski
and I'd say we're gonna meet we're gonna
tell you what it said he would get on
the phone and he'll go we're gonna be
and I would I I guarantee I could work
that uh oh man I guarantee I know
exactly what I'd say by the way I know
exactly I tell one guy this and I tell
one guy that and I say you better make a
deal Trump's foreign policy ideas
extremely convincing to nine-year-olds